[Music]
the new study out this morning shows
Hollywood is still mostly a place for
men University of Southern California
researchers say women directed only 4%
of the top 11 hundred movies since 2007
and just 18 percent of top executives at
major entertainment corporations are
female the report follows the launch of
the times up movement addressing gender
equality and sexual harassment Jamie
yuccas is at LA's Beverly Hilton Hotel
where celebrity supporters will make a
fashion statement at this weekend's
Golden Globes Jamie good morning good
morning in just a few days this walkway
will be covered in red people in the
bleachers will be able to watch nominees
and presenters walk that red carpet
mostly dressed in black
they'll be doing that as a sign of
solidarity in support of victims of
sexual harassment and assault dressing
to dazzle is part of the glamour of
awards season but this year expect a
more somber tone many women nominated
for Golden Globes say they'll be wearing
black I'm very excited to be a part of
that and stand in solidarity with with
all of the women that are gonna be at
the Globes wearing black dresses Allison
Janney is among many nominees taking
part along with reese witherspoon mary j
blige
Saoirse Ronan and Meryl Streep I
definitely feel an energy around the
Golden Globes this year stylist Mikaela
Erlanger has not only worked with Streep
but also Oscar winners Lupita Nyong'o
and Jennifer Hudson I wouldn't be
surprised if you know it was a sea of
black on the red carpet and I think it
will be a very powerful moment the red
carpet moment is part of a larger
movement called times up for New Year's
Day by more than 300 industry
professionals it's already raised a
legal defense fund of nearly fifteen
million dollars to tackle sexual
harassment and inequality not just in
Hollywood but for women in all
industries as The Times up has come to
light there has been more conversations
those conversations will likely continue
on the red carpet
organizers hope journalists will ask why
are you wearing black
to ask her more movement from four years
ago promoted by stars who wanted to talk
about more than just their dresses still
there's skepticism about whether a party
for Hollywood's elite is the best place
to deliver a serious message of gender
equality I don't think you can stop
cynicism actors they are beautiful they
are not you know like the rest of us but
they're using their platform for good
and for change not just for themselves
but for everybody the women behind the
times up movement also want people at
home watching the Golden Globes to dress
in black and then take a selfie to show
their support for victims of sexual
assault the movement tells us that it's
legal defense fund has raised donations
from all 50 states and 60 different
countries Jeff Jamie yuccas thank you
very much